les anniversaires
j'ai comme un gros sentiment de déjà vu
j'ai déjà vécu toute cette journée et
pour l'assassin les exceptions à niveau
aujourd'hui
alors tu veux dire que je vais continuer
à mourir encore et encore juste parce
que je trouve qui aimons assassins c'est
pas ce soir c'est toi qui vas mourir
ça doit être l'anniversaire le plus
bizarre de ta vie alors là t'as pas aidé
[Musique]
j'ai comme un gros sentiment de déjà vu
j'ai déjà vécu toute cette journée
je vais mourir quelqu'un va me tuer
[Musique]
joyeux anniversaire
j'ai déjà vécu toute cette journée je
vais mourir et quelqu'un m'a tuer ce ton
ce soir c'est toi qui vas mourir c'est
terminé on arrive à saluer le travail et
ça lui fait payer
joyeux anniversaire j'ai comme un gros
sentiment de déjà vu j'ai déjà vécu
toute cette journée
il recourt essayé mais ça va pas qu'est
ce que c'est terminé
fils